devant un centre commercial amour par
michael maass vient donner son sang pour
la première fois dans la salle datant
qu'il remplit un questionnaire avant
d'être reçu par un médecin ou un
entretien couverts par le secret médical
ce dernier va déterminer si michael est
autorisé à donner son sang est la
quantité qu'on va pouvoir lui prélever
en fonction de son poids et de sa taille
pour les jeunes hommes se sera 490
litres de maximum je suis passé devant
qui j'avais jamais donné puis ma copine
madiba celle de la reconquête faire nos
achats qui j'ai donné j'ai toujours vu
le temps mais jamais l'occasion piola
j'ai pas peur d'essayer par une fois le
prélèvement terminé la poche de sang est
récupéré et traité dans les douze heures
elle va d'abord subir des analyses
biologiques précise on verrait bien au
niveau des maladies on vérifie à vih les
hépatites jamais avait quelque chose
d'anormal
la poche de sang de michael sera
transférée sur des sites de production
est divisé en plaquettes plasma et
globules donner son sang un geste qui
prend une dizaine de minutes rapide et
sans douleur surtout indispensable des
groupes sanguins sont plus recherchées
que d'autres au moins et ab mais en
réalité existe 33 system générique
différent dans le sens nancy jamais de
point peut avoir besoin d'un avis on
peut en avoir besoin nous mêmes
conditions saines liedson un grave
accident c'est pour sauver les gens le
sang est un médicament unique parce qu'
il ne peut être fabriqué que par nos
frères humains et qu' il sert
principalement aux urgences bien entendu
mais aussi à permettre des
chimiothérapies chez tous les malades
qui souffrent de cancer ou de sida alors
les besoins de sang en ile de france
sont de l'ordre de 1500 traitement par
jour
actuellement on est largement de sa de
cette entrée quotidienne de dons en
raison des intempéries de ces derniers
jours les collectes mobiles de sang ont
été diminués par deux les donneurs sont
donc invités à se rendre sur les lieux
fixes comme au chesnay quant à mickaël
on le retrouve en fin de collecte à la
pause collation pour une première bilan
de ce très bien passé donc je pense que
je recommencerai les hommes peuvent
donner au maximum six fois leur sens
dans l'année
4 fois pour les femmes